alright guys so now that we have learned the market maker model now that we know
how to find our daily bias the monthly bias and the weekly bias now we are
going to use a complete I'm gonna teach you the complete model that has like the
best best win rate out of everything that I've taught before this is like the you
know I would just simply say the best strategy out of all okay and I'm not
even over exaggerating right the moment if you can apply you know apply this
strategy correctly your you are gonna pass challenges you're gonna become a
consistently profitable trader and you will not rely on other people or other
people's signals okay so here is the complete model number one we have to
look for external and internal liquid we have to determine our bias okay so we
are going to use three time frames for this strategy okay previously if we
use two right but remember in the beginning of the update I said that we
are gonna use the third time frame as well later on in the in the course right
so let's assume that this is the daily time frame this is the one-hour time
frame and this is the five-minute time frame because remember for the daily
we're going from daily to hourly to five minute okay so let's say that you have
a purge on the external liquidity on the daily time frame okay and you have the
favorite gap in the discount over here that should be a draw on liquidity so now
once you have the purge you simply drop down
let me mark this out like that you drop down to one our time frame so now price
has taken out this daily high with this external liquidity so now you're
waiting for that time frame to align with your narrative or your bias for the
daily so you want to wait for a market structure shift once you have a market
structure shift on the one-hour time frame after price takes out the daily
high right and you have the target here which is a fair valley gap now notice
here very carefully when price did a market structure shift there was a fair
valley gap right there was a PD area it could be an autoblock here could be a
fair valley gap price comes into that fair valley gap so now right I have from
from here to here this movement okay so from here this is the fair valley gap
this right here I zoomed in a bit okay so now once the price goes into the one
hour fair valley gap we want to drop down to the five minute time frame okay so
from daily we go to the hourly time frame we look for a market structure shift we
wait for the price to come back into the one hour fair valley gap and once
prices in the one hour fair valley gap or autoblock we drop down to the five
minute time frame so now this move from here to that PD area we have to look for
a market maker model inside this move all right so when price goes into the
fair valley gap the move starting from here must have a consolidation a first
consolidation right so now this right here is here okay look at this this
price action I have zoomed in and this is what it looks like so what do we have
here we have consolidation right so that is gonna be our target what do we have
here accumulation phase one which is consolidation number two right what do
we have that we have a market structure shift when price came into the fair
valley gap and then you can simply look to take your entry from the fair valley
gap or autoblock from here onwards when you get a market structure shift on the
five minute every single PD area is going to be respected all right every
single fair valley gap every single autoblock you get an entry here on the
fair valley gap right you have a break of structure you take your entry from
the fair valley gap you keep on doing that until this level is taken out make
sure this level has consolidation guys okay so we don't even look at the
fair valley gap we just know that our draw on liquidity is here the higher
timeframe draw on liquidity is here right but then we want to use the five
minute time frame to increase our chances right to win the trade right we
want to increase our probabilities here so we look for a market maker model
inside this move from this bottom low to this high into the
fair valley into the one hour free valley gap right and once price comes
into one hour free valley gap you look for and scout out the market maker
consolidation in this leg right in this leg around here starting from here
originally on the one hour this would have been our target this fair valley gap
on the daily time frame this over here draw on liquidity but on the five minute
when we drop down this is where we will not identify and scout out the
market maker model so now when price comes into the fair valley gap look for
a market structure shift take your entry break of structure entry break of
structure entry and remember mitigation blocks right so if a
mitigation that we have we can utilize every single mitigation block inside
this move so we'll have a border block here price touch like that let me just
try it out like that wait boom boom boom boom once this target is taken out
you are out of the trade guys very very simple